Soy un ilustrador médico,
y vengo desde un punto de vista ligeramente distinto.
Desde que fui creciendo, he estado observado
las expresiones de la verdad y la belleza en las artes
y la verdad y la belleza en las ciencias.
Y mientras que éstas son ambas, de propio derecho, cosas maravillosas --
ambas tienen en sí mismas cosas maravillosas --
la verdad y la belleza como ideales que pueden ser observados por la ciencia
y las matemáticas son casi como las perfectas gemelas siamesas
con las que un científico quería salir.
(Risas)
Estas son expresiones de la verdad como hechos llenos de asombro,
es decir, son cosas que puedes alabar.
Son ideales poderosos, son irreducibles,
son únicos, son útiles --
a veces, largo tiempo después del propio hecho.
Y de hecho puedes pasar alguna de las imágenes ahora,
porque no quiero verme en la pantalla.
La verdad y la belleza son cosas
que a veces son opacas para aquellos que no están en la ciencia.
Son cosas que describen la belleza de una forma
a veces sólo accesible si entiendes el lenguaje
y la sintáxis de la persona
que estudia la materia en que la verdad y la belleza se expresan.
Si miras a las matemáticas, E=mc²,
si miras a la constante cosmológica,
donde hay un ideal antrópico, donde ves que esa vida tuvo que evolucionar
de los números que describen el Universo --
estas son cosas realmente difíciles de entender.
Y lo que he intentado hacer
desde que me formé como ilustrador médico --
desde que me enseñó animación mi padre,
que era escultor y mi mentor visual --
quise encontrar la formar de ayudar a la gente
a comprender la verdad y la belleza en las ciencias biológicas
usando animación, usando imágenes, contando historias.
De tal forma que aquello que no es necesariamente evidente para la gente
pueda ser traído al frente, y pueda ser enseñado, y pueda ser entendido.
Hoy en día, los estudiantes se encuentran sumergidos en un entorno
en el que lo que aprenden son materias que poseen verdad y belleza
imbuídas en sí mismas, pero la forma en que son enseñadas se ha compartimentalizado
y llevado al extremo en el que la verdad y la belleza
ya no son siempre evidentes.
Es prácticamente como esa receta de caldo de pollo,
donde hierves el pollo justo hasta que el sabor desaparece.
No queremos hacer eso a nuestros estudiantes.
Así que tenemos una oportunidad de realmente abrir la educación.
Y recibí una llamada de teléfono de Robert Lue de Harvard,
del Departamento de Biología Molecular y Celular,
hace un par de años. Me preguntó si mi equipo y yo
estaríamos interesados y dispuestos a realmente cambiar
la forma en que la educación médica y científica se realiza en Harvard.
Así que nos embarcamos en un proyecto que exploraría la célula,
que exploraría la verdad y la belleza inherentes
en la biología molecular y celular
de tal forma que los estudiantes pudiesen entender la imagen global
sobre la que podrían situar todos los hechos.
Tendrían una imagen mental de la célula
como una grande, bulliciosa, y enormemente complicada ciudad
ocupada por micromáquinas.
Y estas micromáquinas realmente son la base del corazon de la vida.
Estas micromáquinas,
que son la envidia de todos los nanotecnólogos en todo el mundo,
son unos aparatos autodirigidos, potentes, precisos, exactos,
hechos de cadenas de aminoácidos.
Y estas micromáquinas controlan como se mueve una célula,
controlan como se replica una célula, controlan nuestro corazón,
controlan nuestras mentes.
Así que lo que quisimos hacer fue encontrar la forma
en que llevar esta historia a la animación
que sería el eje central de BioVisions en Harvard,
que es una página web que Harvard tiene
para sus alumnos de biología celular y molecular
que -- además de toda la información textual,
además de todo el material didáctico --
unirá todo de una forma visual, de tal forma que los estudiantes
tendrán una visión de conjunto de lo que una célula es realmente
en toda su verdad y su belleza, y serán capaces de estudiar
con esta visión en sus mentes, de tal forma que sus imaginaciones se activen,
que sus pasiones se activen
y de tal forma que puedan ser capaces de seguir adelante
y usar estas imágenes en sus mentes para hacer nuevos descubrimientos
y ser capaces de descubrir, realmente, cómo funciona la vida.
Así que comenzamos mirando como estas moléculas se ensamblan.
Trabajamos con un tema, que es: tienes unos macrófagos
que van desplazándose por un capilar,
y están en contacto con la superficie de la pared del mismo,
y están recibiendo información de las células
que hay en la pared capilar, y reciben la señal
de que hay una inflamación en algún lugar fuera del capilar,
que no pueden ni ver ni sentir.
Pero reciben la señal que les hace detenerse,
les crea la necesidad de fabricar
todos los diferentes elementos que les permitirá cambiar de forma,
para salir de ese capilar y averiguar qué está sucediendo.
Así que estos motores moleculares -- tuvimos que trabajar
con los científicos de Harvard y con modelos de bases de datos
de las moléculas atómicamente precisas
y entender cómo se movían, y entender lo que hacían.
Y encontrar una forma de hacer esto
realista en cuanto que demostraba lo que estaba sucediendo,
pero no tan excesivo que el amontonamiento tan compacto en el interior de la célula
puediese impedir que se visualizase.
Así que lo que voy a enseñarles es una versión de tres minutos
bastante resumida del aspecto inicial de esta película
que produjimos. Es un proyecto en marcha
que aún nos llevará otros 4 o 5 años.
Y quiero que observen
y vean los caminos que la célula fabrica --
estas pequeñas máquinas andadoras, se llaman quinesinas --
que cogen estas enormes cargas
que, relativamente, harían temblar a una hormiga.
Pase la película, por favor.
Pero estas máquinas que mueven el interior de las células
son realmente asombrosas, y realmente son la base de la vida.
Porque todas estas máquinas interaccionan unas con otras.
Se pasan información entre ellas;
hacen que ocurran distintas cosas dentro de la célula.
Y la célula, además, fabricará las partes que necesite
al vuelo, a partir de información
que es traída del núcleo por moléculas que leen los genes.
Ninguna vida, desde la más pequeña hasta todos los aquí presentes,
sería posible sin estas micromáquinas.
De hecho, habría hecho que, en ausencia de estas máquinas,
la asistencia aquí, Chris, fuese realmente escasa.
(Risas)
(Música)
Este es el mensajero de FedEx de la célula:
este pequeñín es la quinesina,
y arrastra un saco lleno the proteínas recién fabricadas
allí donde se necesiten en la célula --
ya sea a una membrana, o a un organelo,
o bien para construir o reparar algo.
Y cada uno de nosotros tenemos unas 100.000 de estas cositas
corriendo por ahí, ahora mismo,
dentro de cada una de nuestros 100 billones de células.
Así que no importa cuan perezosos se sientan ahora,
no estás realmente, intrínsicamente, no haciendo nada.
(Risas)
Así que lo que quiero que hagan cuando vayan a casa
es pensar sobre esto, y pensar sobre cuan poderosas son nuestras células,
y pensar sobre algunas de las cosas
que estamos aprendiendo acerca de la mecánica celular.
Una vez que sepamos todo lo que está sucediendo --
y créanme, apenas sabemos un porcentaje de lo que sucede --
una vez que entendamos lo que está sucediendo,
realmente vamos a ser capaces de tener un gran control
sobre lo que hacemos con nuestra salud,
lo que hacemos con futuras generaciones,
cuanto vamos a vivir.
Y ojalá seamos capaces de usar esto
para descubrir más verdad, y más belleza.
(Música)
Pero es realmente asombroso que estas células, estas micro-máquinas,
sean suficientemente conscientes de lo que la célula necesita para cumplir sus órdenes.
Trabajan juntas; hacen que la célula haga lo que necesita hacer.
Y su trabajo conjunto permite que nuestros cuerpos --
entidades gigantescas que ellas nunca verán -- funcione adecuadamente.
Disfruten del resto del espectáculo. Gracias.
(Aplausos)